i've got a bunch of stuff i want to talk
about with michael bury okay can you
pull up michael murray's article from
yesterday or today today is today the
27th or the 20th 28th yesterday berry
comes out with an article uh he said a
few things so this is a business insider
story yesterday the big short investor
michael burry warns the stock market
boom reminds him of the dot-com bubble
and rings the alarm on options mania
okay go to the bottom
he uh uh uh burri said the current
market boom reminds me of come on
rampant speculation that uh uh precipit
precipitated the great depression flurry
of recent tweets that has since been
deleted he does that quite often by the
way the scion asset management by the
way which since 2015 has given returns
of 26
is what his management uh uh uh asset
management company has done tweeted a
screenshot of financial web.com stock
chart the defunct uh the defunct company
behind stock detective and other
financial information website saw its
share prices
uh uh take a nosedive from a high of 28
dollars to fraction of a cent following
the dot-com crash a very common chart
back in the day berry said looks vaguely
familiar moreover the hedge fund manager
compared the bull market during the 15
years of 2000 to the run-up in the
stocks over the last 15 years he
highlighted 94 correlation between the
nasdaq 100's performance in each of the
periods and a 95 correlation for the s p
500 index so he continues he continues
to compare to 1929 what's going to be
happening et cetera et cetera now watch
this
so i kind of looked at some of his
positions and what he has here's his
positions
put options are investments what he
thinks is going to go down call options
the stuff that he thinks is going to be
going up okay put options
he has 700 and
730 million dollars of tesla stock
730 million
it's gonna go down okay put is what he's
got
he's got 280 million dollars of shares
of 20 or plus treasury bond okay etfs
it's called tlt okay on puts on puts
that's going to go down he's got call
options that's
of course it is but watch what he has
call options on even though if you go to
his twitter a profile go to his twitter
profile that says michael jbury and it's
like cassandra or something like that
very weird with his twitter profile
let's go type in michael jaybury
uh michael j bury
uh right there cassandra steve carell
that's roles look what hashtag he's got
rest in peter uh rest in peace alexi you
know who he's talking about rest in
peace petrov boycott amazon boycott
facebook boycott coke that's his hashtag
in his account right and we'll read the
article he has down here as well
you know what he's got for his call
options
and he just increased the amount of uh
uh money he put into this 70 quarter
over prior quarter highest money he's
got of a company that he thinks is going
to go up facebook
327 million dollars of call options
230 million dollars of google he
increased that by 14 quarter of a
quarter but increased facebook 71
percent quarter of a quarter he's got
130 million in mckesson 58 million at
heinz ketchup like heinz like kraft
heinz
53 million in walmart 48 million in
cardinal health 43 million in cvs 9
million of a fund that short treasury
bonds let me say that one more time
that's short on treasury bonds and this
is based on three different things as
he's looking at number one inflation
inflation is not going gonna affect any
of the stuff that he has for call
options with facebook google mckesson
heinz walmart cbs he says inflation's
not going to affect those guys at all
inflation would affect tesla treasury
bonds else et cetera so number one is
inflation it's coming number two is
interest rates are going to go up it's
coming number three bond yields will
increase which means bond prices will
decrease
and he is so certain that this is going
to be taking place that he's putting his
money where his mouth is and he's
predicting big short two is around the
corner this guy's not a dummy
he doesn't say things like this he's not
a guy that's just getting up there and
saying let me like harry dent wrote a
book remember harry dent that said i
don't know if you guys remember harry
dent's old book that he was saying the
it's going to be the biggest market boom
ever the dow jones going to go to 43 000
by 1999. i don't know the exact date can
you put a harry dent
uh uh prediction
you're talking about michael j bury that
a movie was written about and he did
something where everybody thought he was
an idiot
and everybody ended up calling him a
hero because the major prediction that
he made so
if this is the case
and he's talking about a uh where's his
old book the great he has an old book
the next great bubble the roaring two
boom the rory yeah he's made uh
yeah he's he's uh he's talked about
where the market's gonna go he's called
the next crash and a lot of stuff but he
wrote books where made a lot of sense
and then the opposite would happen this
is not him this is michael j berry okay
he's got 730 million dollars of tesla
stock he's shorting
it's not a small amount why tesla of all
things well i maybe the global shipping
crisis has a factory
shipping crisis
you know a he's never been able to meet
his deadlines with cars
when inflation goes up people are not
going to have to money to go out there
and just buy stuff like that he's also
been against tesla in terms of their
market cap versus their output of cars
for a long time so this isn't anything
new he's saying with tesla's overpriced
with the whole uh sledgehammer to
souffle kind of analogy so he's been
talking about personality for the last
year and how could you not think that
elon could get a little distracted with
everything else he has how much can he
really put into
tesla that's necessary how long is the
put and how long are the call options do
you know does he say does he give a
duration you can probably go up there
and find the timeline to see what's
going on but but the point is when a guy
like this talks you have to pay very
close attention so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you